foreign
let's go out to the Oklahoma City and
talk to Courtney what's up Courtney
hello hello
what's up
oh I'm just I almost sick kids that
sounds par for the course these days fan
sounds to be the way it is right now
they are lucky to have you what's up
because I had a question for you
basically how do I
too much basically
um yeah where does the question come
from
I know a thing or two about this
Courtney and my therapist loves it
he went through the highway patrol
Academy while I when we've been married
for 12 years home in my whole our whole
marriage as well so it's just it's in
the blood but what do you do for a
living I'm a nurse practitioner oh my
gosh really
so your kids have a cop and a
um
nurse practitioner as parents yeah
over here have you rubber root like like
rubber padded the house yet
um
I take the whole backpack of medical
supplies with us and here we go gosh
there's always that Mom and it's
Courtney
um so do you know my background at all
yes I listen to you every chance I get
okay all right so I work that is off to
you you've probably you've probably
heard me talk about this but my old man
was a homicide detective and he was a
SWAT hostage negotiator so same thing
right
and he would because he loved me no
mistake about it because he loved me
he would go to work and on the family
desk he would put Polaroids because we'd
have digital cameras back then of guys
getting out of jail
that he had helped put away and he would
say hey these guys may get out come
looking for me if they knock on the door
don't answer
and I remember
growing up being like okay and so every
time somebody ring the doorbells like
this is it right this is the one so in
his attempt to love me and by the way
uh well we'll get to that in a second
his attempt to love me it created quite
the nervous system right yeah and I I
still to this day cannot enter a
restaurant without sitting with my back
against the wall
so weird I can't I can't do it like if I
don't sit that way I just feel like I am
sitting on an exit or whatever oh dude
hey I didn't know that everybody didn't
walk in and look at all the exits when
they walk into any room anywhere
nope that's not normal I didn't know
that until I saw my first counselor and
she's like you're insane right
um and
so I I wanna and I did research on the
mental health of medical practitioners
and so y'all are just a barrel of
monkeys too right yeah for fun just stop
talking is real great
yes it is it's actually you have to have
that and actually your sense of humor
gets so so
dark because you have to right you have
to I get that and that's fantastic
the challenge is um here's the way I
describe it about about my dad
it shifted his entire bell curve of the
world and here's what I mean by that you
and me Courtney were in Oklahoma City
we're walking down a dark alley and
we're heading to an opera together
because you're into Opera that's super
weird I wanted to go to the Pantera Show
but no Courtney had to go to Opera so
we're going down the down the alley to
go to Opera and another person is
walking towards us
999 times out of a thousand they just
walk by us 9 .98 999th time they're like
hey I got two front row seats to the
Opera y'all want them and we're like
yeah that would be great
and then the thousands time
they pull out a hatchet and chopped me
and you open little pieces right yeah my
dad's job a hundred percent of his life
was that thing that never happens to
anybody because it's not if it's when
that's correct and so I got a ticket the
other day because I was driving way too
fast
and the guy pulled me over I smiled he
caught me I was breaking the law I
handed him my stuff I was like well done
man and he looked at me kind of weird
and I go I was going way too fast I know
that you know that and he smiled went
back wrote me a ticket and I was on my
way
and that's the majority of the
interactions but your husband has seen
all the training videos and he's been
involved in a few and he's his shop talk
is that one time it happened to that guy
and that one time happened to that guy
and suddenly it's happening to all of us
right yeah
uh how old are your kids
eight five and almost two oh geez Louise
on a stick okay
so
I'm gonna tell you how it's happened how
I've tried to uh
the way I'm trying to do it right now
okay and you can just take this for what
this is
um two big phrases
well actually one phrase there's the
share don't scare have you heard that
statement
yes okay
I do think that if you have a police
officer as a dad this is a highway
patrolman and a nurse practitioner is a
mom you get a really unique beautiful
powerful insight into how the world
works
and things that could happen and I think
that's actually really amazing and it
would be a tragedy to hide that from
your kids
the other side of that is there is hey
uh
uh any number of 12 guys who are getting
out of jail might murder you hashtag
just saying there's that or
there is hey we don't answer the door
when Mom and Dad are gone we just don't
know Daddy works with really scary
people Mom helps people
um who have had really scary things
happen to them we just don't open the
door for people period And there's a big
difference there here's another example
with my 13 year old son I talk about
this all the time we go to Waffle House
but I don't talk about enough and I
probably should
is we have a 9-1-1 rule me and my wife
me and my kids that they know
if I say
hey this is 9-1-1 walk out that door
right now there's no questions there's
no talking there's no anything they head
out that door
and I had that um recently somebody came
in and they were messed out of their
minds
and it was it was enough that I went oh
this ends badly for everybody in this
tiny little restaurant
and I looked at my son and said this is
a 9-1-1 moment
if I if I tell you to go into the
kitchen and walk out that back door
don't ask any questions you all got that
back door and he said yes sir
and I thought we had a moment and I said
this is 9-1-1 head out the front door go
and he I mean dude his credit he got up
and started heading out the door and as
he headed out the door of course the guy
got up to go to kind of cut us off a
little bit and that allowed me to
intervene and I gently intervened and he
didn't have the money to pay for his
food and I paid for his food and I said
hey it happens to all of us I think it's
time for us to go and it ended very
peacefully
yeah and then I was able to debrief that
but that what I had in place was not hey
those guys at those restaurants are
gonna kill you
so that my son walks in and scans every
restaurant
and also I put him in a position and
kind of uh I mean probably not the best
place to take your kid right and I took
him there because I feel comfortable I
feel safe and I've got a plan with him
and then we debriefed and that was the
important part on the back end hey you
saw this thing I want you to know like
here's why I did what I did here's what
I would have done if this had gotten
sideways and you I'm so proud of you
because the smartest thing you could do
is take yourself out of the situation
not try to be John Wick right you see
what I'm saying like it's it's coming up
with a plan on the back end and I think
it's okay to say they're scary people
if something happened yeah I was gonna
say something happened that you were
like oh no
well I so I also have had a like a legit
stalker and so like I'm always like lock
the door shut the house like put the
alarm on and I think that I've put the
fear of that situation even though he's
not around right now
um on to my kids too and so I don't want
them to be fearful like there's the
boogeyman behind us but at the same time
like be safe and the reason I brought
this up was because I hurt my
eight-year-old saying something to my
five-year-old that I was like oh I did
that to you I'm so sorry what was it
um I can't remember the specifics but it
was just like we have to make sure that
the alarm's line we have to make sure
that the doors are locked and we have to
be beside mom all the time at the
restaurant like she was very specific on
like all the rules that I have
and I just don't want her to have that
dampness on the world uh the the glass
is the dark glasses on that me and my
husband do yes and she's with the kids
but I don't want to minimize that y'all
also have the light too and I think
whenever I work with police officers and
I work with police groups and I work
with medical professionals and Med
students I always want to make sure they
don't miss the light because they see
that too yeah because you've seen some
insane recoveries
even when somebody has passed away
you've seen families come together in
Waiting rooms that probably still gives
you Goosebumps if you thought about it
right
and your husband has seen people who
were out of their mind on drugs get well
and come by and say hey I just want you
know I'm doing great he's seen that too
and he's pulled people over and probably
kept them from hurting themselves or
killing themselves and so there's light
too it's just that often in these
professions there's so much Darkness we
miss it right
and so that guy at a restaurant come up
to my husband and say thanks for saving
me yes exactly and it's easy to go yeah
I was doing my job
Hey where's the exit right it's easy to
blow that off and it's like no no no
that's equally as valid that's light
and that guy that pulled me over I've
been much more careful
and so he did his job I didn't and now
I'm being more careful he may have saved
countless other people for me being an
idiot driver you see what I'm saying so
there's light there too
what I think it's important to let your
kids know is not so much that the world
is out to get you which in a weird way
it is right it is
But Mommy gets nervous about some things
so here's how here's another example
it's kind of unrelated but it is related
I am terrified comically like insanely
pathologically of heights
like a second story like at my
neighbor's house on the second story I
don't like it I don't like looking over
the rail I put myself up against the
wall and so when my kids run up and lean
over because they have no fear of
anything
I will grab their shirt and I will look
at them and they'll turn and go Dad and
I'll say hey this is just for your old
man
this is just for me because I'm nuts and
they'll go okay Dad now okay yeah I have
sat with a family after somebody fell
off of something really high
it's not just for me but mostly it's
just for me all right
and so it's both and I think it's coming
up with the plan and letting them know
oh hey the lights I mean the locks and
the uh alarms that's Mom that's just for
me nobody's coming in the house guys
nobody's coming in the house if they do
there's a plan
but nobody's coming the house guys this
is just for Mom this is just for me I
like whenever dad's gone I like sleeping
with it like with all the stuff on
and letting them know oh Mom's a little
bit out there but we'll do that for Mom
and they will slowly start to see this
and if you see somebody who's choking in
a restaurant you see somebody who's been
hurt
um the other day Josephine came home and
I was telling something to my wife my
daughter came home
or came up on the porch where we were
talking
and she said dad why do you look like
that in her classic Josephine way and I
said
I had a really hard day I had to talk to
somebody whose kid is very very sick and
it made me sad
that's all I didn't tell him that
somebody that I care about and loves kid
has cancer in its terminal and it's
scary I just said Somebody's got a kid
in the sick and made me very very sad
because I don't think kids are supposed
to get sick like that and she crawled up
in my lap
and so she knows I told her she knows
and also I never once expressed a dad's
out of control and number two
um I let her know like I got emotions
and I get sad too but I don't want her
wearing the emotions of my house and I
think you had that experience with your
kids like hey we gotta lock this thing
up they're starting to absorb the fear
and the fear is becoming theirs not
yours and I think it's important to take
ownership of that fear back
and all police officers all nurses all
doctors everybody I think it's always
going to be attention
between my kids got to know they gotta
know what it's like out there and also
not over
um explaining things before they're
ready to hear them
right and that's a scary place to be but
that's the world we're in
and I'll just end the call with this
thank you thank you and your husband
for pulling over idiots like me who are
driving too fast for helping save
people's lives on the side of the road
for showing up
to the medical profession which has been
just a dumpster fire of the last few
years
thank you thank you all thank you all
thank y'all thank you and I know you
want to get this one perfect too get
this one perfect too your kids are
resilient and they're going to be tough
and they're going to have their issues
because Dad was a cop and mom was a
medical professional
and also man they won the lottery with
you too it's amazing
thank you